[Music]
welcome to the smartphone awards so
there were a ton of smartphones that
have come out in 2018 from january and
ces straight all the way through all the
launches and events until december now
and all these phones have different
strengths different weaknesses different
goals different designs different things
they do well and not as well they're all
similar in some ways but they're all
different so naturally at the end of the
year we got to break it all down and
reward the very best of them
so there will be a bunch of categories
and for each category there will be an
overall winner and then there will be if
there's a worthy one a second place sort
of a runner-up and if there's some more
good stuff there's an honorable mention
so without any further ado
let's get started first category is best
big smartphone so nowadays most
smartphones are already pretty big right
they've gotten bigger year after year
all these phones in 2018 are way bigger
than the phones from 2015 but this award
goes to the one that takes the best
advantage of all that extra space that
makes the most use of being big both
with hardware and software and the
winner for best big smartphone of 2018
goes to
samsung galaxy note 9 and this one's
honestly a no-brainer if you've got to
have a big phone the note 9 has
absolutely one of the best big phone
feature sets you can possibly get it's
the absolute best display in any phone a
six inch amoled and the huge body holds
a four thousand milliamp hour battery it
keeps the headphone jack it has
expandable storage it has dual cameras
there's no notch and it has room for a
stylus that doubles as a remote control
but it's not just about having big
hardware what really wanted over for the
note is having all this software that
takes advantage of it all all the s-pen
features the multi-window support this
phone is a power user's default it's the
big phone of the year no doubt and then
the runner-up for best big phone of the
year is going to go to
huawei mate 20 pro this was the last
phone i reviewed this year kind of snuck
in at the buzzer but they killed it it's
not quite as big as the note 9 but it
still has a 6.4 inch amoled it has a 4
200 milliamp hour battery and it has
triple cameras instead of the usual one
or two all at different focal lengths
there's no pen which is actually fine
for most people but there's also no
headphone jack and it does have a notch
but still this is one of the most
complete big phones of the year both in
hardware features and software alright
so the next up category is best small
smartphone the best compact phone of the
year you see small smartphones are kind
of a rare breed nowadays all throughout
everyone's lineup phones have just
gotten bigger across the board but you
can still do great things in compact
packages not as compact as phones used
to be a couple years ago but still there
are some great small phones out there
also by the way i think this is the
closest contested category some really
good ones here but the winner for best
small smartphone in 2018 is gonna go to
iphone 10s this one's got a 5.8 inch
display like i said not a super small
phone but to win this award you have to
do everything in the small phone that
the big phone does and iphone 10s truly
does pretty much everything the iphone
10s max does just with a smaller display
and smaller battery there's basically no
other drawbacks obviously it's one of
the fastest chips with that a12 it has
the same dual cameras as the bigger
phone same ram and you know what you're
getting with ios there's not many people
out there regretting buying this phone
by the way i'm gonna leave my my list of
all the reviews of the phones i talk
about down below so spoiler alert that's
kind of like a winner's section but that
will be below anyway a very close second
place a runner-up to best compact
smartphone of 2018 is going to go to the
pixel 3 5.5 inch display so it's even
smaller and some might even say the
pixel 3 is an even more appealing buy
than the bigger brother the pixel 3 xl
the only thing you're losing out on here
is you have a smaller display and a
smaller battery but you even keep the
stereo front-facing speakers and the
dual front-facing cameras and then
runner-up right behind that is going to
go to samsung galaxy s9 back to a 5.8
inch display and this thing has a lot
going for it already great design we all
love that already three thousand
milliamp hour battery the only points
you gotta dock for it are having one
less camera than the galaxy s9 plus and
for having a little bit less ram but as
of you noticing those things are both
pretty small okay next up
best camera so for some people like me
having a great camera is super important
in a smartphone if you take a lot of
photos and videos it's just encouraging
to know that you'll be able to capture
the moment in as high of a quality as
possible i happen to like to take a lot
of photos on my smartphone so this is a
category that i've spent a lot of time
analyzing and it's come out crystal
clear this is probably no surprise if
you've watched the videos but the winner
for the best camera and a smartphone in
2018
is gonna go to the pixel 3 and pixel 3
xl there is one camera in this phone and
the amount of software magic google's
done with this one is nothing short of
amazing there were of course plenty of
other good phone cameras this year but
google's hdr plus and software magic
plus night sight and all the incredible
shots i've gotten with it put it clear
and far ahead as the favorite camera
ever in any smartphone it's so good in
second place though i have a camera that
does
slightly lesser photos but that i'd say
does much better video and audio and
that is the iphone 10s iphones have been
sort of the king of video and
smartphones for a little while now and
the 2018 iphone is no exception to that
rule if you're trying to do a lot of
video on your smartphone you should get
the iphone and i'm going to give my
honorable mention for cameras to the
huawei mate 20 pro for an excellent use
of three cameras obviously with three
unique different focal lengths i really
like the super wide angle camera
especially for a lot of things now of
course lg and others also did the whole
triple camera thing but this one happens
to be the best quality of those three
cameras all right next award
best battery life and this is this is an
important one for most people because i
feel like a big complaint a lot of
people have about their current
smartphone is it just doesn't last long
enough so it's good to see some
smartphones focusing on not getting
super super thin but actually giving you
a long lasting battery life plus you'll
get extra points in this category for
things like fast charging and wireless
charging and the winner sneaking in at
the end of the year for best battery
life i've had actually ever in a phone
but of course of 2018
is the huawei mate 20 pro this one i
don't want to say it shocked me because
i knew it would be good i just didn't
know it would be this good so it's a 4
200 milliamp hour battery 6.4 inch
display but the aggressive memory
management combined with the actively
changing resolution and fast charging
and wireless charging all this combined
meant i literally never think about
battery when using this phone i could be
using it for six straight hours in a day
and end the day with 40 left or
something ridiculous it's really
impressive what they've done with this
phone and all that in a phone that's not
even that thick kind of sorcery well
done huawei runner up for best battery
iphone 10r turns out combining the best
soc in any phone with the apple a12
with a particularly low resolution is a
recipe for a super long lasting battery
life this is the longest lasting iphone
i've ever tested and happens to be a
bunch of colors and other sweet stuff
too but 10r very good battery and then
honorable mention will go to
red hydrogen one this phone it is
obviously pretty thick but it's packing
a 4
500 milliamp hour battery making it
officially the biggest battery cell i've
ever held in my pocket or at least in a
smartphone anyway it does have pretty
fast charging doesn't have wireless
charging but it just lasts for an
eternity on battery so that's a good
sign okay next up the design award
and this is an interesting one because
for a lot of the year we got these
complaints of
every phone kind of looks the same are
we at peak smartphone and this is kind
of when they're all doing glass backs
dual cameras and a notch like every
single phone but i found that the most
interesting looking most innovative
designed looking phones this year came
from a lot of boutique manufacturers
trying to avoid the notch
so they knew that if they could say they
made a totally bezel-less phone with no
notch before apple
then you'd have a big hit on your hands
and that spawned this whole genre of
these crazy looking phones that were
trying their best to be bezel-less but
then put the front-facing camera and the
earpiece and all those sensors behind
the screen or in some other places it
was really interesting to see anyway the
point i'm getting at the design of the
year for 2018 is going to go to
the oppo find 10. this was i mean what a
head turner of a phone this year they
decided to go with a full-on motorized
slider that holds the front-facing
camera and ir sensors and full facial
recognition system it pops up every time
you unlock the phone
and i don't think anyone can really
speak to the long-term durability of a
system like this yet
but the result is definitely a really
fascinatingly beautiful phone that could
totally end up in a museum in a few
years also there's a pretty good chance
in the future we're going to laugh at
what we had to do to get these
bezel-less designs back in 2018 but i'm
going to give honorable mentions to the
xiaomi mi mix 3 also a slider and the
nex s which was just the single pop-up
camera okay next category
best budget phone in 2018
this is an important one this year
because if you haven't noticed pretty
much every phone that came out over this
calendar year of 2018 has been more
expensive at launch than the one that
came before it i used to say it often
good phones are getting cheap and cheap
phones are getting good
now uh half of that is still true but
basically a great budget phone is
becoming more and more rare but they do
still exist so the winner for best
budget phone of 2018 goes to
you guessed it the xiaomi pocophone f1
this thing turned a lot of heads when it
came out it's not available everywhere
still and it's not the only good phone
in this price range but it just got so
much hype and then it does a lot of
things well snapdragon 845 six gigs of
ram four thousand milliamp hour battery
and it's pretty well built and it's
around 300 bucks give or take with a bit
of shipping but even knowing numbers
don't mean everything like this phone
performed pretty well the skin wasn't
too overwhelming but you could just
flash another rom on it anyway and on
top of that it went and took down the
iphone 10 in our blind camera test so
it's just just got a lot going for it
you guys already know i'm so busy with
flagships i don't get to spend a lot of
time with budget phones unless they
really pop up on my radar but this one
really earned its time in my pocket and
i hope we see more phones like it next
year i'm going to do honorable mentions
in this category as well and that would
be for the nokia 7
and the honor 8x
get it honor i had to all right next up
is the award
i hate to have to give
but i have to give it it's the best
the biggest bust of 2018. we all have
disappointments okay i get it like
there's mistakes mistakes get made
sometimes two or three or eight or nine
things go wrong or maybe it just didn't
live up to the hype
or you just didn't see something going
the way it did
you can probably already tell what i'm
getting at no doubt the bust of the year
for smartphones in 2018
was the red hydrogen one it was so
frustrating because i wanted this phone
to be so good the whole video if you
watch it it's just let down after
letdown which is only so bad because i
love so many other red products and what
they do as a company but that being said
i'm still crossing my fingers for those
modules
or hydrogen 2 whichever comes first
but that's all coming in the future next
year this was the bust of 2018. all
right next up
the most improved award this goes to the
phone that just improved the most year
over year now for as much as phone's
gotten more expensive over the last year
not a lot of them got significantly
better to warrant that difference in
price like you know the new iphone looks
like the old iphone the new samsung
looks like the old samsung that's part
of the whole tick tock design strategy
but you have to reward the ones that
really take a big leap forward so the
winner for most improved smartphone of
2018 goes to
razer phone 2 and they earned this award
in a pretty new gaming phone category by
basically attacking all the things that
were weak about the first razer phone
and keeping all the good stuff so they
sort of repositioned it from a hardcore
gaming phone to a flagship that happened
to be great at media and gaming so they
added a glass back for wireless charging
they dropped in a glowing rgb logo the
cameras are improved they kept the
front-facing speakers they kept the
awesome 120 hertz display but made it
brighter and then made the whole thing
water resistant like last year i
wouldn't have necessarily recommended
the first razer phone to most people but
this one is much more complete much more
daily drivable it's kind of like going
from a prototype car to a full finished
production version with all the trims
like it's much better so this is uh it's
always sort of had the specs it's just
much more daily drivable now so then
last but not least the biggest award of
the night
literally
it's the mvp the smartphone of the year
you can see it as the best phone the
most complete phone the most impactful
phone
either way there's only one voter and
that's me so the winner of the mvp the
smartphone of the year for 2018 goes to
the oneplus
6t now this one's truly deserved but if
you scroll back up through the awards
it's not really the best at anything
actually it's arguably the fastest
android phone but there's no award for
that but it does pretty much everything
very well and then makes a couple
sacrifices in the right place to bring
the price way down so in a world where
phones are approaching 900 1000 eleven
hundred dollars
the oneplus 6t this phone brings a lot
of flagship performance and kind of
flagship design too down to literally
half the price it's hard to go wrong and
now that this is also in stores too this
is a phone i'm recommending to a lot of
people and they're enjoying it too now
it's going to be a tough app for them to
follow next year but we kind of always
see it coming because we see the phone
they release early in the year then a
couple months later there's the t
version that's way better
but i gotta say they've done a great job
with the 6t this year so then my
runner-up for the mvp is going to be the
samsung galaxy note 9. this is what you
might call the most complete phone of
the year not a lot of phones make it
feel like you're getting more than you
paid for especially at a thousand
dollars but if you want something that
checks every box note 9 checks every box
is basically the only flagship left with
no notch with a headphone jack with a
stylus built in and then with that
incredible display with a variable
aperture camera and with all around
high-end specs it's just it's checking
every box and then my mvp honorable
mention will go to the huawei mate 20
pro
still not available in the us and still
not the best reputation of a company in
the us either but this phone did a lot
of things right so i'm talking best
battery life that i've ever used in a
smartphone which is really impressive
you get the triple cameras of different
focal lengths so again high quality very
versatile you have to color power button
and a great design and great overall
performance uh not a whole lot not to
like easily my favorite huawei phone of
all time and one of the best devices to
come out in 2018. so there you have it
it's the smartphone awards of 2018. like
i said earlier there was a little bit of
a sentiment that we were sort of all
getting the same smartphone over and
over
but really when you look at it there has
never been a better selection there's
something for everyone genuinely like
whether you're into smartphone
photography or video or you're working
on a budget or you need a compact phone
or you're really into something that'll
last you all day with a big battery
even phones that aren't like winning
awards that are on this table if you
brought this lineup of phones to six
years ago these would all be incredible
choices so it's kind of a good time to
be alive so thank you for watching this
annual awards show it's been a pleasure
to host for 2018 hope you enjoyed
i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace